[Applause]
good evening one and all as you can see
on your left its Parliament light door
TV it's a snapshot where you can view
parliament videos you can share it you
can engage with it here the online media
online Facebook Twitter and social
things are acting as a bridge to you to
the people of UK where you can go and
engage with these debates from last two
years there are six million views from
this platform and under supervision of
dr. Sean Shastri and every road I push
Kellogg represent you updates from
Parliament live dot TV so a queue
discussion so how you can engage so can
we have a count like how many you engage
with online news like any of the news
app or news platform can we have a count
almost all but from where you get the
news feeds from third party from from
something else but the actual news the
90% of news is is from the Parliament
from the hot smoke and yes people doing
aged with that as well people engage the
dead people search for it people share
it on Twitter even though legislators MP
share say hey there's my speech today my
question today and do you want to have
do you want to have a look and really
English back then the sister website
known as hands out like hands our
Parliament dot UK as well where you can
read it so all the transcripts from
1850s or are archived at the good thing
is like we are analyzing the oldest
democracy and yes there is nothing fake
it's only real so on the right side you
can see a snapshot which it's a
statement by by one of the House of
Commons librarian she said that if they
said the legislators will believe it so
they will share some stats shares from
research briefings and all you can
subscribe to it and whoever will engage
they will believe it so being the data
scientists I analyzed okay how do people
engage with it so we have Google
Analytics view behavior from referrals
so what all referral sources are getting
engaged with which videos and we created
personas out of it we used
suppose learning of non-negative matrix
factorization so if you can see the
formula there it's V for views of U
matrix decomposed into W and H where the
W is the basis vector and H represents
the coefficient so if there are n cross
M matrix size we decompose it m n cross
K and K cross M where K is the kind of
persona and we found that there are
three kind of personas if you can see
there are three columns here one
represent the direct source another
represent the search behavior and the
third represent the social behavior in
the search if you see the clustering
then diagrams it's Google and Parliament
not UK so people do search using Google
and then engage with it and that Google
and Parliament don't you kiss having a
different behavior than direct and
social media so that means people are
consuming a bit differently when
consuming in different platforms we did
the same kind of stuff for for pca
principal component analysis and we
found that yes 99 percent of the data is
covered in that in this metric and you
can see in top middle parliament that UK
and google are in the triangle and
purple color which is somehow closely
related but all the other stuff facebook
Guardian and parliament services are
coming in the red cluster and direct in
the left bottom is somewhere different
so where direct represents you go on the
parliament lab dot UK website and you
search whatever you want online archive
video or the live video the last thing
we thought like okay what are the
features coming out of it so when you
see this matrix here is w which shows
the clustering in the new grams and the
edge H are the features from those
features we found that okay these social
search and direct are having different
kind of behavior they mostly view from
desktop but if you see the social column
and the mobile it's 40 percent that
means it's democracy on the go because
of the massive use of Internet massive
use of devices it's people are engaging
back youngsters are engaging back and
it's on your palm another thing to see
here is the life so social is more in
the live culture the second column for
search
the twice average time it's two 45
seconds on an average that means people
actually engage when they they manually
search for it they want to get engaged
twice the time then they are engaging on
social media and the third is direct so
direct is somewhat like okay I got to
know about something I'm going there and
watching it I might be interested in
some stuff I might not be and I might be
interesting some few bytes of the day a
video but not much before thinking I
would like to say that politics and
debates are there from like thousand
years but the battlefields are not
online thank you so much
[Applause]